speculation grows over whether the US
will drop out of the Iran nuclear deal
there is renewed pressure tonight to
bring home several Americans held
prisoner in the Islamic Republic
correspondent Richardson tells us where
things stand tonight from the State
Department good evening rich now good
evening bread and the families of
Americans detained in Iran say they hope
this represents an opportunity president
Trump says he wants changes to Iran
policy by May 12th if not he says he's
going to withdraw the United States from
the Iran nuclear agreement the wife of
one detainee in Iran says she hopes that
the surrounding discussions those
surrounding the Iran nuclear agreement
will provide an opening for the u.s. to
bring one of its own home mr. president
please help us please save our family
please
rayma has been case into any negotiation
on Iran and going before May I put a lot
of help in May and we're counting on you
watch's husband she why us - dn't at
Princeton and an American citizen
authorities arrested him nearly a year
and a half ago when he was in Iran
researching its history for his PhD an
Iranian Court sentenced him to 10 years
in prison for spying under the cover of
research a senior State Department
official traveled earlier this month to
Europe to meet with leaders from the
United Kingdom France and Germany to
push them to agree to stricter penalties
against Iran officials say while in
Europe they also met with
representatives from Iran and demanded
they released the Americans they're
holding now the US will engage in more
discussions until that May 12 deadline
and watch.you says that she hopes that
that provides an opportunity and a
greater chance that she will see her
husband again soon and their
five-year-old son will see their father
I'm so scared and I fear more more more
and more for his safety
I hope our government and mr. Trump can
give him hope and can can make our
family whole again a State Department
official says the United States at every
opportunity discusses those the several
Americans who are detained in Iran they
say this is the type of behavior they'd
like to address and want to address with
Iran its capture of Americans who were
there its ballistic missile testing and
its aggression across the Middle East
Brett Richardson at the State Department
rich stacks